well I think what the country wanted
tonight was real clarity and a sense of
consensus and I'm afraid we haven't got
that the basic message stay alert just
isn't clear enough and there are more
questions than answers in the prime
minister statement and we now have the
prospect of England Scotland and Wales
with different messages and pulling in
different directions so that that
clarity isn't there and the consensus
isn't there now I appreciate there will
be more detail tomorrow and there'll be
further questions to be asked but at the
moment there's a gap between what we
really needed tonight what we got but a
couple of weeks ago you asked for a
timetable to be laid out now you have
that timetable conditional though it is
no I accept that and we did ask for it
and I said at the time it will be
conditional I don't criticize that I
well understand that the dates are
provisional but some of the detailing
what's been said tonight causes real
concern so millions of people are being
told particularly construction and
manufacturing effectively go back to
work tomorrow that's in about 12 hours
time but they're being told at the same
time to go back to work if possible not
using public transport that's a real
logistical problem for tomorrow morning
for millions of people equally the word
guidelines on what safety at work needs
to look like they were very vague we've
gaps in last weekend and we haven't seen
any new guidelines so lots of businesses
trade unions and employees are going to
be saying am I going back to a safe
working environment so I don't criticize
the conditionality and the fact that
further down the line conditions will
have to you know be fulfilled but
tomorrow morning poses a real problem I
think for millions of people who are
being told as I say go back to work but
but don't use public transport and I
think lots of people will be scratching
their heads tonight to see to say well
how's that actually going to work